كل دوله لها مسؤوليات اساسيه
للامتثالي الى القانون وضمان
العداله لكافه ساكنها ضمن حدودها وكل دوله
غير قادره او غير راغبه على تطبيق القانون
همم محكمهتنا ياتي دورها فيما يخص تلك
الحالات وتلك الدول التي وافقت على قضائي
لذلك وهو مجلس الامن التابعي للامم
المتحده بعض الحالات الينا وهذا ما فعله
فيما السودان قبل 17 عاما وما حصل
همم
كافه الاطراف
والتعاون مع الامم المتحده
مع الاطراف الاخرين ايضا
مثلا خلال فتره القصيره الماضيه اييي
الذين طريقه تحقيقات مشتركه في ليبيا مع
خمسه دول اخرى اسبانيا والمملكه المتحده
وايطاليا وهولندا وكذلك
رانيا
ان شاء الله
مشاركه الجميع همم
السفر وهنا لك حتى جرائم ضد الانسان هي
لتشمل الجميع فهذه بعض الامثله التي نحاول
من خلالها التغيير اسلوب اعمالنا في
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في مكتب على
الاقل والاذلك لان نريد ان نبدو وكاننا
كثير والحديث بل يجب ان نفي بوعودنا وما
نقول له والا فسيكون هناك فراغ كبير جدا
بين الوعد على العداله وبين تقديمه وهذا
الفراغ اذا ما استمر بالاتصال فلا احد
باهميه القانون الدولي
اهميته الان اكثر